grazie per la splendida presentazione
allora sono giovanni landi sono qua in
veste di esperto e appassionato di
realtà aumentata realtà virtuale adesso
mi occupo di realtà aumentata di realtà
virtuale ma il mio background strano io
infatti vengo da luciano grafia però ben
presto il motivo per cui solo trasferito
negli anni dell'università da firenze a
genova mi sono accorto ben presto che
dello scenografia io amavo molto di più
l'aspetto tecnologico quello di raccolta
del dato in particolare di
visualizzazione del dato quindi la
cartografia è per questo che rapidamente
subito dopo la laurea insieme a dei
colleghi abbiamo fondato uno spin off
accademico in cui occupandoci di fondi
duro e di corallo avevamo bisogno della
terza dimensione per visualizzare i dati
che raccoglievamo con la varia
strumentazione luciano grafica
segretamente parallelamente al mio
percorso accademico io coltiva una
grande passione per la grafica 3d e
questo mi fece un pochino prendere mi
fece un pochino prendere la mano vedendo
l'opportunità di creare degli ottimi
prodotti di comunicazione scientifica e
iniziate impadronirmi di strumenti
tipicamente usati per la realizzazione
di video games come quelli che federico
fascio chi ha fatto vedere stamattina
questo ad esempio è uno dei progetti del
nostro spin off in cui abbiamo una
rappresentazione dettagliatissima fino
alla singola specie di un ecosistema
molto diffuso nel nel mar ligure
ecco iniziare appassionarmi quindi a
grafica 3d animazione 3d e
visualizzazione 3d real time in quegli
anni diventava possibile accedere cioè
si stava democratizzando una tecnologia
chiamata appunto realtà aumentata che
permetteva di trasportare questi
bellissimi oggetti 3d molto dettagliati
fuori dallo schermo del computer e
proiettarli grazie a degli algoritmi di
computer vision che riconoscevano delle
immagini del marker
trasportare fuori dallo schermo questi
oggetti e visualizzarli nel nostro mondo
nel mondo reale
bene da quel momento questa è una gran
seo l'ha pensata per lo scenario di
prima che siamo riusciti a far uscire
dallo schermo
ecco da quel momento ho iniziato ad
appassionarmi delle altre aumentata a
focalizzare sulla realtà aumentata e ad
applicare a tanti sarà applicata
tantissimi ambiti non solo allo
scenografia alla comunicazione
scientifica ma anche il marketing la
presentazione del prodotto i beni
culturali
ho avuto la fortuna nel 2013 di
presentare un mio piccolo lavoro una
campagna di marketing per un marchio di
abbigliamento indipendente di firenze e
vincere contro dei competitor
incredibili uno dei pochi premi
attualmente presenti per la realtà
aumentata questo will wright l'inventore
di sin city che mi da questo bruttissimo
statue di cartapesta che però è il
premio per la miglior campagna di
marketing in realtà aumentata non
eravamo tanti c'erano altri compiti
della grande agenzia inventato una
splendida soddisfazione che a me e
motivato ancora di più a puntare tutto
su questa tecnologia
quindi adesso il mio lavoro attuale è
diffondere e far conoscere a più persone
possibili tutte le possibili
applicazioni della realtà aumentata e
della realtà virtuale perché parlo di
queste cose molti di voi probabilmente
ne hanno sentito parlare ma in maniera
separata
bene sappiate che gli strumenti i tool
hardware software e anche di design per
realizzare esperienze virtuali è
aumentate sono esattamente gli stessi
io introdurre molte delle presentazioni
sulla realtà aumentata è la realtà
virtuale con questa semplice
illustrazione una fortunatissima e
l'estrazione di una pubblicazione del 94
che è diventata storica e continuo di
milgram
è un banale segmento un gradiente che ha
ai due estremi il mondo reale e il mondo
completamente virtuale ma virtuale in
maniera ideale qui io tutti i sensi
impegnati in una percezione che di fatto
è artificiale quindi qualcosa di
fantascientifico questa e l'estrazione è
molto utile perché permette a tutti
quelli che mi devono spiegare alla
platea dove sta la realtà aumentata di
dire ecco la realtà aumentata stappato
prima della meta dei contenuti milgram
ossia io la percezione del reale nel
quale o aggiunti degli elementi virtuali
se non fosse chiaro il continuo di
milgram io utilizzo immediatamente dopo
un'altra illustrazione questo è una
scena di un film che sicuramente tutti
voi avrete visto del 1984 che però
rappresenta la visione più chiara e
definita di quella che è la promessa
tecnologica della realtà aumentata
questa una scena di terminator
schwarzenegger arriva dal futuro
completamente nudo fuori da questo bar e
dando un'occhiata al suo ambiente vedete
le moto degli oggetti e la sua
intelligenza artificiale riconosce la
sagoma di questi oggetti è appunto
penalizzato nel tipo di veicolo la marca
harley davidson eccetera e lui inizia
con questo robot inizia impossessarsi
tutti gli elementi che mi servono per
vivere e uccidere sarah connor
ecco quindi abbiamo è stata una buona
definizione di realtà aumentata di credo
che stiamo cercando di
realizzare la realtà virtuale in questo
momento è un po più calda perché è stata
molto pubblicizzata
sicuramente molti di voi avranno sentito
parlare della storica acquisizione da
parte di facebook di una piccola startup
chiamata la piccola per modo di dire
chiamata dal plus rift per ben 2
miliardi di dollari una delle
acquisizioni più giù strapagate della
storia della silicon valley
quindi abbiamo detto realtà aumentata
realtà virtuale la realtà virtuale
praticamente si basa sul mount display
che permettono di vivere esperienze
completamente immersi nei a meno almeno
per quanto riguarda il campo visivo
ecco queste due tecnologie sono i due
degli elementi fondamentali di una
potenziale rivoluzione tecnologica ma ci
sono altri tre elementi che
caratterizzano la nostra epoca che ci
portano verso questa visione anticipata
dal collega questi sono i dati vediamo
in un epoca in cui abbiamo una
produzione di dati spaventosa
le fotografie che scacchiere tutti
questi dati oltre a essere volume
tantissimi sono già in formato digitale
quindi federa bili combinate insieme
processabili in maniera mai viste nella
storia dell'umanità questi dati
chiaramente noi stessi il nostro corpo
irradia dei dati questi dati chiaramente
devono essere filtrati processati
analizzati nel giusto contesto per
essere uno strumento che ci aiuti
effettivamente a prendere delle
decisioni a vedere l'andamento di
fenomeni che a volte sfuggono i nostri
sensi
la cartografia e uno degli ambiti in cui
più classicamente il dato viene
contestualizzato pensiamo anche alla
risoluzione che alcune che alcuna
sensoristica ha raggiunto un'ecografia
che fino a pochi anni fa era di
difficilissima lettura adesso permette
di avere
la ricostruzione completamente
tridimensionale e tangibile del
dell'oggetto in esame questo caso un
feto l'altro elemento importante di
questa rivoluzione tecnologica e quello
che avete in tasca ossia il mobile
mobile è importante perché ha messo
nella tasca di ognuno un potentissimo
processore per iniziare un uno schermo
di risoluzione crescente in altissima
risoluzione
una fotocamera che tutti usiamo
quotidianamente e una sensoristica
mediamente avanzata pensiamo a gps
pensiamo angelo scopi eccetera ecco
questo insieme poi al questo arco e che
noi teniamo in tasca insieme al quinto
elemento di questo mio questa mia
ricetta che è il were a boy ossia
tecnologie che in qualche modo che è un
tema talmente vasto che meriterebbe un
tet a sé stante guerra vuol
semplicemente distribuisce permette di
distribuire questo hardware e questa
sensoristica in giro per il corpo per
essere più più più usati che diciamo
secondo me sono gli ingredienti per una
rivoluzione che potrebbe dare all'essere
umano finalmente dei superpoteri quindi
realizzare un desiderio che tutti
sicuramente più nerd di voi hanno avuto
almeno una volta nella vita
ma facciamo subito il primo esempio ok
non sta andando avanti
ok questo è un dato diagnostico la fonte
dentisti italiani e dall'idea della
risoluzione che io riesco ad avere ad
esempio di un'immagine del tessuto osseo
ecco questo è un paper dell'università
di monaco in cui grazie alla realtà
aumentata io riesco a dare al medico
l'immagine del suo dato dall
esattamente sovraimposta alla gamba del
paziente bene questa appena ho visto
queste illustrazioni che ho pensato a
uno dei più classici dei superpoteri
questa è la vista a raggi non è altro
che la vista la gente ci siamo la
tecnologia è la facciamo subito un altro
esempio abbiamo parlato di guerra ball
parlato di guerra poli ma era molto
diffusi in questo momento sono usati per
monitorare la nostra attività fisica il
nostro apporto calorico la nostra
idratazione i nostri cicli di sonno
potenzialmente questo web potrebbe
portarci ad avere la super forma tra
entrarci ad essere se ascoltati questi
questi guerra potrebbero aiutarci a
raggiungere una super forma
questo è il paper molto importante
diciamo un momento di svolta perché per
la prima volta appare questa definizione
di realtà diminuita
era una conferenza di realtà aumentata
del 2013 cui questo gruppo di ricerca ha
proposto questo nuovo questa nuova
visione la realtà diminuita è
praticamente utilizzando le stesse
tecnologie di computer vision la
possibilità di escludere dal campo
visivo grazie al solito 3 kg
dell'ambiente alcuni elementi in questo
caso viene selezionato il vaso e poi
frame dopo frame questo caso viene
eliminato dal nostro campo visivo pam
invisibilità un altro super potere anche
questo chi di voi ha mai visto questo
oggetto chi lo conosce è un disco
volante è ok
qualcuno di voi lo conosce questo è uno
dei guerra bolchi più caldi più sexy in
questo momento è un braccialetto si
chiama mio prodotto la tau di club e in
breve che cosa fa questo lecce le pulci
alle fermate
prodotti dalle contrazioni dei muscoli
dell'avambraccio e li trasforma in input
per qualsiasi applicazione uno
sviluppatore volesse volesse sviluppare
una delle più interessanti che ho visto
è un'applicazione che permette grazie al
movimento del braccio di governare in
volo di uno degli altri protagonisti
dell'innovazione
il drone in questo video era c'è la
stessa sensoristica del mio ma non
incastonata in un braccialetto qua sono
semplicemente degli elettrodi e vedete
che questo operatore moravetti trony con
la forza della banda raggio ok abbiamo
la telecinesi ma andiamo avanti
uno dei dati che noi abbiamo più a
disposizione sono ad esempio in ambito
umanistico smart city eccetera la
disposizione a una fattura di tutte le
le infrastrutture tubi impianti eccetera
all'interno di una città
questi visualizzati così sovraimposte
alla realtà non sono molto leggibili
ecco la realtà aumentata permette questo
è un paper molto interessante che è
stato citato da quelli dagli autori di
quei tempi per in cui si vedeva la
caviglia in cui praticamente creando
questo buco quindi creato un contesto
dentro cui visualizzare il dato noi
riusciamo ad avere una visione molto più
leggibile molto più intuitiva del di
quello che ci serve ossia la
collocazione le interconnessioni dei
vari impianti nel sottosuolo di una
città io sono un appassionato di storia
dell'arte questo è un quadro a un
affresco a cui sono molto affezionato
alla trinità del massaggio io quando
vedo questo quadro non vedo soltanto uno
dei primi esempi di pittura
rinascimentale ma vedo anche la prima
rappresentazione prospettica corretta
geometrica
nella storia della belle arti visive e
quando vedo questo quadro io vedo anche
la sua composizione eccetera e tutti
questi livelli sarebbe bello averli
disponibili in un'esperienza di
fruizione di questo bene culturale ed è
per questo che ho sviluppato
un'applicazione che vi permette
inquadrando il quadro di ricevere una
serie di spiegazioni sulla composizione
sulla costruzione geometrica della
prospettiva in esso è rappresentata e io
trovavo questa possibilità con una forma
di super vista o quantomeno super
sensibilità la possibilità di avere dei
livelli ulteriori addirittura
direttamente nel contesto in cui questo
super potere vi serve ok
chi di voi ha mai visto un array di ivo
brodo così organizzato questo a una
telecamera che permette di produrre dei
fotogrammi in sferici questi fotogrammi
sferici appaiono così ma possono essere
mappati all'interno di una sfera e visti
attraverso uno di questi ed mounted
display
questa è la versione per ricchi e che
quello che vi è stato regalato
l'effetto è esattamente lo stesso
l'effetto esattamente lo stesso e questo
permette di avere visioni completamente
immersi vedi video girati ad esempio in
cima tour eiffel eccetera io intravedo
della possibilità di teletrasportare il
proprio punto di vista in luoghi
altrimenti inaccessibili
ecco però io posso portare il mio punto
di vista però io non posso interagire
con l'ambiente nel luogo dove mi sono
eventualmente proiettato ci sono
ricerche anche in quel senso
c'è in ambito industriale questo
progetto posso vedere le mani di un
operatore a distanza che mi guidano
nella manipolazione di un oggetto
allo stesso modo c'è una bellissima
ricerca del del tan cipollata dellai mai
chi in cui io in remoto possono
manipolare oggetto dei feedback taking
back questa io la vedo come la
possibilità di essere b qui manipolare
qualsiasi un certo in qualsiasi luogo
del mondo
dobbiamo stare attenti però chi di voi
si riconosce questa foto
questa tecnologia è cresciuta molto
rapidamente troppo rapidamente i form
factor di della rivoluzione mobile
ancora
portano a user experience che rischiano
di isolare le persone e di annullare il
vantaggio dei super poteri che ho
elencato prima per cui sta a noi
scegliere di design migliore i fattori
di forma perché questa rivoluzione
tecnologica non ci danneggi ma sia anzi
siano da noi rendere questa tecnologia
antipa nostra disposizione un reale
superpotere io confido negli artisti
dagli artisti sono arrivati gli utilizzi
più belli e più interessanti di queste
tecnologie
questo è un progetto di un collettivo
messicano in cui praticamente due
performer pure con dei movimenti
fotografati si guardano il corpo
rispettivamente e uno vede il corpo
dell'altro mentre osserva se stesso
questa non è altro che di fatto il nome
poi chiarito trent machine to be another
è una macchina per l'empatia la stessa
espressione è stata usata da chris milk
per definire questo splendido
documentario che che significa
realizzato in un campo profughi della
siria ma l'ho realizzato utilizzando
quella rei di camere che vi faceva
vedere prima quindi il filmato e spero
quindi ognuno chiunque guardi questo
filmato può decidere dove orientare il
proprio punto di vista che dettagli
guardare del frame complessivo e
l'empatia che si crea fruendo questa
nuova tipologia di prodotto audiovisivo
e ordine di grandezza maggiore tanto del
chris milk si riferisce alla realtà
virtuale come the machine il potenziale
di questa tecnologia e dell'empatia
creata da questa tecnologia è stata
presa stata presa molto sul serio anche
a livello istituzionale questa è una
visione del
del documentario in questione al forum
di davos e le reazioni alla visione di
questo documentario sono state di enorme
attenzione per il problema dei profughi
in sé in siria e di un enorme ha
rivelato l'enorme potenziale di questa
nuova tecnica di filmmaking quindi
adesso sta a noi trasformare queste
tecnologie che affollano le nostre
tasche le nostre case i nostri salotti
in delle macchine che possono di fatto
darci i superpoteri
mi aspetto molto da voi
per cui in bocca al lupo grazie
si scatenò la sua storica grazie